According to my research,
there are 26 countries in Latin America.
So the most widely spoken language in
the world is obviously Latin.
Right.
Good evening everyone.
Today I'm going to talk about what are
the most commonly spoken languages in
the world.
A lot of people want to know that.
What are the most commonly spoken or
most widely spoken languages on earth?
Well,
it depends on how you measure it.
It depends on whether you measure only
native speakers or if you measure the
uh,
the number of second language,
third language speakers,
all that.
Uh,
so let's just talk about a couple of
different ways to count the number of
speakers.
So the first way is just by native
If we do that,
then mandarin is the most widely spoken
language in the world with 1.1
billion speakers,
that's billion with a b.
And that's only Mandarin.
That doesn't include all of the other
Chinese languages in China.
Uh,
if you include those,
that would be another couple hundred
million.
But just native speakers of Mandarin 1.1
billion.
You mentioned that billion after that.
Number two is English,
which is far,
far behind with 330 million native
speakers.
Uh,
as you might expect,
it's in the top couple,
but it's only number two after,
after Mandarin Chinese number three is
Spanish with 300 million people.
So what's not far behind English?
Judging by the number of native
speakers,
it's not far behind English,
but we'll get to that again later.
And number four is Hindi slash or do,
uh,
that's widely considered to be the same
language.
It's Hindi in India,
but it's Urdu in Pakistan or when
spoken,
um,
in,
uh,
by Muslims.
And you've written in the Arabic script,
but it's usually considered the same
language because the core is the same
and they are mutually intelligible.
So same language,
basically.
Number five is Arabic with 200 million
people.
A Bengali with 185 million people is
number six.
Bengali is up,
the language spoken in Bangladesh and
that area of the eastern part of Indian
sub continent and number seven is
Portuguese with 160 million people.
Number eight is Russian with 160
million.
About the same as Portuguese and
Japanese.
122 million,
puts it at number nine,
and then German is number 10 with a 100
million.
Then we have Punjabi Javanese that's
spoken in Indonesia,
and then French is number 13.
Umm,
so let's compare that to the number of
speakers including second language
speakers,
but proficient second language speakers
proficient meaning that they can speak
it fairly well.
Uh,
even though it's not their native
language.
So number one is still mandarin Chinese
with 1.3
5 billion.
So basically the speakers of all the
other Chinese languages also learn
mandarin as the national language of
China.
That's why there's an extra 200 or two,
250 million speakers of Mandarin Chinese
when we include the second language
speakers.
Now English is surprising one,
well not surprising,
but impressive with that.
It's still at number two with 1.2
billion speakers,
including the second language speakers.
So that's quite a difference between the
number of native speakers.
330000001.2
billion.
So that's something like 870 million
people have learned English as a second
language and speak it proficiently.
That's quite impressive.
That's a large percentage of the world's
population.
Uh,
when we get to number three,
there's a change.
It's not Spanish,
it's Hindi and Urdu because in India and
in Pakistan,
those languages are not the native
language of everybody.
But a lot of people who speak a
different language learn Hindi and Urdu
as a second language.
Uh,
so they can communicate with speakers of
other languages in the Indian
subcontinent.
So that has a 750 million proficient
speakers if we're including second
language speakers.
So that displaced Spanish from number
three,
but no Spanish is still at number four
with 530 million speakers including
second language speakers than Arabic.
Still at number five with 300 and
million,
319 million speakers.
And that's because a lot of people in
Africa learn Arabic as a second
language.
Uh,
number six is French with 274 million.
So French is another one that jumped way
up the list when we included second
language speakers.
That's because there are a lot of
countries in the world where French is
not the native language,
but it's the official language or it's a
language that is spoken by a large,
a large proportion of the population,
so that includes much of Africa.
A French is widely spoken in Africa and
a lot of different countries,
so that's why it goes up from 75 million
to 274 million.
It's almost 200 million people speak
French proficiently as a second
language,
so that's quite impressive to number
seven we get a language that wasn't even
on the list for when we calculate it,
just native speakers and that is molay.
Slash.
Indonesian.
That's another one of those languages
that has two different names because
people in different cultural groups or
different countries call it something
different.
So Malaya Malaya has Malaysian language
in Malaysia and it's Indonesian language
in Indonesia,
but same language,
almost entirely the same.
Just some different vocabulary and
different accent and that kind of thing.
That one goes up to 270 million if we
include second language speakers.
And that's because in Indonesia it's,
it's not the native language of very
many people.
I think it's five to 10% of the people
who speak it as their native language.
But it is the national language and
everybody learns it as the Lingua Franca
and as a language of education that of
business and everything.
So it doesn't have that many native
speakers,
but it has a huge number of speak
proficient speakers,
including second language speakers.
So Indonesian and Malay with 270 million
people.
And then after that,
um,
I didn't keep track of all of them.
But it's interesting how the most
important languages are not necessarily
the ones with the most native speakers
because languages can be important based
on their status as a Lingua Franca.
So we see that with melee and
Indonesian.
So just because a language has a lot of
speakers doesn't necessarily mean that
it's the most important or most
influential language on a global scale.
So another factor that we can think
about introduced into the conversation
is how many places that language is
spoken in over how wide of a geographic
area is it spoken?
So if you think about Chinese,
it's spoken basically only in China.
If we're thinking of Mandarin,
it's spoken in China,
it's also spoken in Taiwan,
although they claimed Taiwan as part of
China.
Um,
and it's also spoken in the Chinese
diaspora to a large extent,
but basically it's only in China,
just that one country.
It's a big country.
It's an important country,
but it's only that one country.
So does that make Chinese the most
important language?
Is Mandarin the most important language?
Just because it's spoken by the most
people?
Well,
I would say no because on a global scale
it's not used that much by a non native
speakers.
And it's not used between people of
different countries as a Lingua Franca,
it's not used as an international
language of business.
So I would say it's not the number one
most influential or important language.
Even though China has any emerging
country and it's a powerful country,
an important country,
it's still not the most important
language in the world.
I would say it.
English you could argue is the most
important because it has such a huge
number of second language speakers but
it's,
but they're dispersed all over the
world.
So everywhere you can find people who
speak English.
So it's arguably the most important.
Um,
Spanish is also a very important one
because Spanish is spoken in so many
countries,
uh,
and it has native speakers in so many
countries.
So Spanish could be,
uh,
one of the top most influential
languages,
Arabic as well as spoken in a lot of
different countries.
Arabic is a tricky one though because it
has a huge number of dialects and the
dialects can vary quite a bit.
So whether you can communicate with
speakers in a different country or not,
if you learn Arabic,
that's an entirely different issue in
that complicates the matters with
Arabic.
So I would say Arabic is not one of the
most important though.
It's,
it's up there.
It's quite important and quite useful
around the world,
especially in Africa and the Middle
East.
French is globally important because of
that,
because of all the places it's spoken.
It's spoken in a lot of former colonies
in Asia and the Caribbean and South
America a little bit.
Um,
and especially in Africa and in many
countries.
In Europe,
French is spoken,
so French is also one of the most
important languages because of its
dispersion over a large area.
I would say English,
Spanish,
French,
maybe Arabic would be the most important
on a global scale if we're thinking
about the number of countries and the
widest geographic area.
All right.
Those are just my thoughts on the
matter.
Those are the most important,
most widely spoken languages in the
world,
I guess.
What do you think?
Which ones are the most important?
Leave your comments below and let's have
a chat about it.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Talk to you later.